this is the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Jack Pryor who is a senior
consultant at red cat digital
recruitment and thanks for joining me
mate
you're welcome how you don't have to
come in yeah I'm good it's 6:30 p.m. in
the hunted offices yeah late night class
session mm-hmm yeah good man I
appreciate your time so as I was saying
Jack where I always always like to start
how did jet Pryor get into the wonderful
world of recruitment I think it's the
it's not a really really interesting
story okay very honestly I think it's
the same for a lot of people where you
naturally you know you fall into it for
me it was a case of I left University I
needed a job straight away because my
mom was making me pay rent straight away
and I know honey and then I'd start my
CV on read and immediately get people
calling grads you know you do and do
recruitment you wanna do sales and for
me what degree do English literature at
the University of Kent - one I'll take
it
so yeah it was a case of I need a job I
want something quick only something I
can guarantee and recruitment and sales
are the thing that was just coming
through the door and to be honest I was
being a bit lazy in my search you know I
always had a bit of a creative streak
about me I was like great to be a
journalist it's great to be a freelance
writer and the aim for me initially was
going to sales a recruitment do a lot
writing in my spare time and then see if
I can enter a career one so fair time
yeah I didn't know about that yeah
once I had a portfolio in front of me
obviously I never started doing that I
just started and what it was was I was
just getting all these calls for cream
in sales cream in sales
my idea as I say was just to be quick
and easy and then it was it was all my
final interview ready actually I went to
go meet my mates for a beer I'm suited
booted I'm having a good time like guys
how weird is it that I might actually be
in recruitment
I hadn't really assimilated that that
could be my career you know like no mate
fits perfectly really yeah and for them
they were like you're chatty
you always want to be like active you're
a hard worker it works really well for
you okay and it wasn't until they said
that I was like
oh this could actually be a job where
it's not just something I do for a year
and then suck it off
interesting that obviously you thought
about it that way like quietly on which
I'm assuming has been useful through the
the peaks and troughs of recruitment do
you not I mean that's quite interesting
that you had that early on yeah
definitely I think that's one thing my
director Jamie yeah used to say to me
all the time is like don't be scared
about being a recruiter
because you are a recruiter you can't
hide from it the difference is is you're
trying to be a good one you're not
trying to be Sharky you're not trying to
be too salesy and to upfront and roots
people you are actually trying to do the
job well so don't be scared about being
a recruiter because there's nothing
wrong with being a good recruiter yeah
and I think that was a switch for me as
well was like wow you know it's positive
to do that well so what does that mean
then on your tinder profile you put a
recruitment consultant or do you put
headhunter or do you put search
researcher researcher proud about it I
think I was scared about telling people
I was a recruiter really to start
because you tell people like I'm
recruiting especially when especially
every time I went to like a anytime I
met people in tech outside of work yeah
and you say oh I'm a recruiter that like
because I have such bad experiences so I
was worried about it to start with again
I think it's more cases when you think
I'm actually okay at doing this I don't
mind being a recruiter and telling
people yeah I think it's only when you
can be like yeah I'm I'm not trying to
be awful no well we'll definitely dive
into that so I guess quickly so
interesting you mate said that but did
you have a perception recruitment then
or was it yeah oh you did absolutely and
it was a and what was it from the from
the people that you interview it really
and I had so many negative experiences
interviewing a lots and lots of places
how many how many places do any of you
are and over a dozen really and some of
them were like full half-day interviews
well like Assessment Center
yeah Assessment Center know me this pen
tell me this person sits down the nature
that you just met yeah yeah I remember
there was one distinct one where we went
to assessments and about 30 people they
one exercise are really light hours and
it was speak to the person next to you
for five minutes then pitched the person
yes I actually liked that because that's
rated everything you need attentiveness
ability to speak in front of 30
strangers
ability to be concise the rest of it
what did you find out about that person
if he's listening
Alex Caressa mo whence the University of
Bath was a DJ in his spare time I don't
know what you doing now mate but I
remember no hey it was very sound
half-italian
I believe don't say you got to know I
really got to know ferm friends by the
end a lot but by the end they start
doing so they did the bit where oh yeah
half of you come with us
half of you staying home Wow and then
you get cut half you get cut did you get
cut I stayed all night and then after
you stay there like oh yeah we're gonna
do one-to-one interviews there's three
people interviewing about 15 people I
was one the last people that they
interviewed I've been in a room for
maybe two and a half hours no food no
water
shut up actually in like a grey room in
voxel and then you're like this is awful
like I wouldn't want to work for your
cut and then all that came out of that
I've like a successful yeah he done
really well mate was do you want to
relocate to Wimbledon or can you work in
wooden house I'm not really I want to be
in central and never heard from them
again bad that yeah and then when I
started that when I started recruitment
got a LinkedIn the cheeky woman tried to
add me not absolutely not you're
horrible yeah it's just a shame that I
think cuz again if you think about it
firstly but crimine hasn't got the best
name and then graduates straight out are
unique you trying to work out what they
do then get obviously and have some sort
of experience like that then like you
could have just gone one way I'm not
dumb of it and then whatever you ended
up doing or whatever grows end up doing
who then get approached by recruiters
yeah all of a sudden have that massive
like horrible gray room in Vauxhall
treat locker animal when do you not I
mean there was a point when I actually
started going back to people I'm not
interested in grad really Rubin
ourselves anymore I'm not interested
don't message me about there any yeah
I'd sucked it off and then suddenly I
think that was actually the time that
red cat got in touch NARS like oh this
might be different and red cat was
definitely a complete change in what I
perceived was a perception before Rick
Catlin just out of curiosity Sharky yeah
blunt how do they sell it to you then
because that must have been a big reason
as to why you thought that yeah yeah so
in one these half-day assessments
they were talking about like oh how are
you gonna deal with the growth like I
think they really liked me to start with
at least and then it was more like ah
how you gonna do with a grind they're
like really pushing my buttons how are
you gonna deal with the grind yeah how
you gonna deal with working hit on 9:00
p.m. every night I was like no like and
I was like they were asking me like oh
yeah II like to do any sports like yeah
I like sports I like martial arts no
like how you gonna do that was like it's
a gym box across the road they do
jujitsu there and they were like no you
won't have the time because this this
and this not you know get a lunch break
they're like no barely ever and I was
like trying to make you not like it yeah
yeah like they immediately wanted to
test your resolve from day yeah yeah
you're missing the point on you if you
want people to work for you you're
testing resolve from day one yeah and
the only thing they talked about with
money as well and the thing is money is
important in recruitment
you know no one would do it if they were
only in 25 grand yeah that is the honest
truth but they're also telling people
who are gonna be jumping on like an
18-grand base salary no you could be
earning 200 grand in your first year
it's like get real like let's be honest
with each other
I got sole done and I build 24k my B for
trip yeah that's exactly it here right
and they promise you all of that I
remember specifically looking at their
job advert and it was like because I was
it still at uni when I applied and it
was like ah you can get a limo to work
on your first day and then if you're the
best bit on your team you get a limo to
work I think about this now actually I
was getting driven to like central
London from Croydon in a limo let me an
hour 45 minutes but I'll be like guys
honestly I'll get the train yeah but
they were selling me the whole trip like
internal Pru tissues are only in my
first year I only earned fifty five
grand which is like the lower than
everyone else I'm on my own the Graduate
team so you know projected earnings of
60 to 80 K in your first year yeah who
does that
like there'll be a few people out there
definitely there's gonna be a few people
saying I must be trashing cream if I'm
not doing that but I think there'll be a
lot of people that don't it was one of
them I think the majority of people
don't even touch no I may actually love
that story I haven't had this story
about that for a while because I think
one of the big intent is behind this
podcast is actually was part of that
because one of my friends said let me
show him I think
recruitment try it okay I looked into it
and yeah that what he told me was
hundred gram first yeah obviously once I
got into recruitment and I never got
told about being rejected every single
day and all these things and but one of
the intentions behind this was actually
to share an actual real perspective or
recruitment yeah so I'm glad you shared
that because I don't had to stall about
that for a while it's quite fun to enjoy
that but that's a big reason as to why
one of the big reasons why I like to
start this as well just to actually
allow people to actually have a roo
insight into what can actually be a
brilliant brilliant career and has every
opportunity to actually change your life
which I'm sure will dive into you know
that thanks for sharing that man no
you're welcome in the journey so I guess
then also you got to read cat digital
right so I'd be interested in just for a
contrast like what do they then dive
into then resonated with a chapter the
Graduate that was like now recruitment
not for me what what what sort of
changed I sound like a sales pitch right
now on so we have three major values
okay honesty integrity and transparency
I think that genuinely pervades the
culture from day one as soon as you walk
through the door there's none of this
there's none of this nonsense where you
they try and make you feel like you I
think a lot of the big companies always
like are you have you've had to earn to
be here to interview us I was so much
better than you though we unload and
there's none of that there's nice people
they're normal people they're you and I
and I think I didn't see any people like
you and I and these big companies I was
interviewing for they were all you know
thought they were big shots they're
normally they drive an Audi TT you know
but from day one it was like just
chatting with a mate about like you know
can you do this job why do you want to
do this job are you actually gonna work
hard yeah I'm gonna work hard and being
very honest like you know some days you
will have to stay late and you'll have
to put in the hard graft but it depends
about how much you want it my manager so
it's part of my interview process I to
do a presentation about why red cat and
why recruitment for me so I did that in
front of my my current manager now my
current director Jamie now and and the
woman who heads up our diversity and
inclusivity and also our learning
development desk Sarah so I did it in
front of Briony Jamie Sarah who all
still work with now
Briony ask the really cutting questions
she was like I can see all through your
presentation you know it's good but I
can't see anything that says you care
about making money and I think you need
that to be a driver that's all about to
tell her that my choice is where do I do
do I try going into sports for a living
which is jiu-jitsu for me or do I try
going into something work and have a
house and I said if you give up the
thing you love to try a career to even
give it a shot you know I'm gonna work
hard
hmm and that was the sort of sort of
discussions we were having people do
well if they really care about working
hard if they care about earning money to
live a proper life for them and I think
Redcat has more of that culture than
being sort of flash and in your face and
all you know we're going to our beef run
incentives and flying in a white jet and
you know I'm not gonna name the company
that broke down earlier this year but we
think we all saw them very well you know
with the opposite to that we're just
real people they're always people that
really connected me them yeah 100
percent first day walk him through the
door you know how many people are in red
cap I'm looking at Simran who's our
internal crew over there and she's gonna
mouth at me 29 right now which I knew
off the top of my head yeah okay so yeah
a nice size where for me like I've had
my own experience but and I always ask
and people this but from my own
experience I would personally rather
have a work for a business who where I
did have access to the owner of the
business and these things like from
especially in a sales capacity
especially in recruitment there's pros
and cons obviously to both but I think
for me obviously recruitment can be a
job which is really unforgiving and to
actually have direct access to the
business owner to the person that's
paying your wages and all these things
is what I found really motivate really
motivating and I think that's a really
unique thing to have access to and
actually really valuable early on yeah
and so yeah that makes sense I think for
me as well I think we say this to people
when we interview them as well and I
mean it genuinely
Tony who's my MD we want to work for
Tony he's a really really good guys
built a business from the ground up from
you know a tiny little tiny little
bedroom with his mates to actually
building out
twenty nine people he cares about
business this is baby and we care about
making sure we do well for him you know
we want to do well for ourselves but we
also want to do well for our team yeah
and when if we have a bad month at red
cat and you know one team has done
exceptionally well you know we all still
take it on the chin for everyone because
it's like we are a team a whole
company's a team it's not just my desk
and I'm hiding TVs in my drawer you know
I want to make sure everyone else can
succeed whether it's junior senior
manager level we're all there to help
each other and I think you don't get any
of that sort of snarky behavior you
would have a big yeah no that's that's
that's special man that's class so I
guess so so basically just to frame art
for everyone listen and so see you're
you've only had one recruitment job
that's been Redcat yeah and you've been
there comment two three years yeah yeah
okay cool so and you've you sent out it
so you've always done it's always been
no plan recruitment now but you did a
bit of dual desking during that time or
yeah yeah okay and then the final thing
then what market do you operate in I do
software engineering so so far in
general tech okay general tech yeah
loads of careers out there in there yeah
okay cool so firstly let's break down
this journey that you've been on then
and how are you first 12 months in
recruitment
um I thought I was really bad when I
started okay I think there was
definitely like I remember my my manager
Briony mentioning again she said of a
while ago she was like you know we
weren't a hundred percent sure if you're
gonna start billing yet you're like
you're you you have all the right tools
in your locker but when you actually
gonna start putting it together and it
took me about three months to do my
first deal she's an awful Bay is longer
than most people do I think it took me
about three four months when there's a
warm desk and I had someone on James
Dean the other day
12 months May 12 so James 12 months too
bad no no I'll take it was you was you
how give me a bit of context that was
you straight source and Jobs was you be
doing what what was was a set up so we
started we started sort of one desk
directors with me and three other
graduates we
the first couple weeks doing pure
training so I think we didn't get on the
phone until the end of our second week
and it was all about learning database
learning about how to find what a good
CV looks like and then it was actually
trying to get on the phone I was so
nervous about getting on the phone I
mean you probably tell ready I'm too
chatty yeah but I hated it on the phone
I was scared and I'm also a bit of a
perfectionist like I hate the idea of
picking up a phone and trying to talk to
someone who's worked in tech for ten
years and then try and talk to him about
a job that I know nothing about and just
go through a tick box and yeah I
wouldn't never wanted to be that
recruiter because I couldn't do it for
my own sake I would have I just would
have hated it and I hated it from day
one when I was like I mean up my
colleagues will laugh at me I'm still
scared of the phone like I still bear
what do you mean by scared to find that
as in I'm as I barely pick it up
I don't do my own it on oh you'll never
see me call for a list of people really
nice because I don't think that's
effective recruitment in my at least in
my area you know my mates are software
engineers don't pick up the phone and I
ring him let alone people that you know
and I'm their best mates they're not
gonna see it when a stranger's number
especially if I've called them in the
past or emailed them and it says maybe
red cat digital they're gonna be like
absolutely don't have time for this no
they work with their headphones in all
day they're not gonna take it out to
take a call from Pinterest him you know
I barely pick up the phone yeah and also
I barely use job boards because job
boards aren't populated by good
engineers most the time because it's
such competitive market you'd rarely
need to have a CV on a job board so I
never go through those sort of sprinting
sessions on the phone but you must have
to do that at Lee but I had to do that
at the start to even get used to what
how did you overcome that then I think
it was sort of a natural progression of
my own understanding how to talk to a
candidate about and I think that came
with learning more about the the
industry so how do you learn about the
industry it was my second week and my
director said you going over the weekend
I want you to do one thing by back on
Monday that's do a short presentation
just for me and the free other grads on
the table about your industry and we all
had to do it and honestly all I had to
do was that and I started setting the
wheels turning about actually
understanding so you know I can still
remember the exact website was front-end
ham but if I get hub and that was the
exact website that was still got pin
them up
now if I ever need a refresher about
understanding go back to it and look at
it cuz that was gonna be my question
actually like how did you how did you go
about cuz let's tech the tech market is
clearly obviously a booming market yeah
loads of tetra crews out there it's
extremely saturated etcetera etcetera so
might be people listen and are really on
the net recruitment Korean these things
so I guess so your what you just saw
shared what you went to then tell me
what you learn yeah but what so what did
you then go to then you just went
straight into the untwine understand
more about the actual job itself as a
whole word that you trying to understand
a bit more about the industry as a whole
what was the would be your advice
basically to someone to try and upskill
themselves in terms of knowledge we had
this exact same question a red car a few
years ago where someone had joined
recently onto our team yeah and one chap
on our team was a very very experienced
recruiter who I think he'd admit that he
wasn't you know obsessed with the main
knowledge be really cared about process
okay versus me who's the complete
opposite well I care about tech and
understanding it but I'm probably not as
stringent on processes maybe I should be
and this girl on our team she said you
know I've got the two recruiters here
who I haven't been learning from yet can
you give me a bit of advice and I said
look for me
first thing learn your industry and spin
out because it saves you all the time
when something goes bad or you're on a
BD call you're talking to a can and you
get tripped up that the main knowledge
will save you you're in a house really
really helpful and then the other chap
he said you don't need any tomato so
just need to know recruitment and it
will save you over and over again yeah
so for me it's whatever you think your
approach is gonna be best if you do
think you're naturally quite a salesy
person which I don't think I am then
process is great because it helps drive
your natural energy and sales enos into
doing the right things and you
eventually pick the right things up I
think if you are like me who thinks
they're probably quite creative and you
know interested in English limo
yes I'm basically like a set of poet if
you are an English literature grad I
think learning your domain knowledge is
really important and to be honest I
would vouch it for anyone because I
think there's as you say a million tear
creatures out there such a saturated
market if you don't know you're talking
about how are you gonna talk quite up
later
candidate or a hiring manager when
they're asking the genuine tough
questions about is this right on the
speck and you say I don't know like you
just look like an idiot but it's what
sets on it so just quick just to run
that off yeah think that the people
listening how do they go about stunned
getting that domain knowledge because I
think that is more if I think of the
conversations I have a business owners
they want their recruiters to be seen as
a go-to person they're marking a big
part of that is having the domain
knowledge right so I guess obviously we
did that presentation so it's in one
that was really useful if you were to go
back or whatever or give yourself advice
what would you do to top secure yourself
to to start understanding or get more of
that domain knowledge in the tech space
so I don't think there's an easy short
answer and I think that's the difficulty
every business owner will have to face
and I think we have tried to do that
before or at least I have tried to do
that before I've try and do quick easy
wins but for me personally I not only
did you know short presentation when I
started you then have to do the very
obvious thing which is actually speak to
candidates and you just ask because your
director has asked you to ask but
actually taking the answer and write it
down and see if we can understand why
secondly for me a thirdly even I do
talks for you know who the General
Assembly oh no so General Assembly are a
quite well-known bootcamp for people
moving into web developer UX or product
roles okay I do talks panel talks or
presentations to web developer graduates
there I do talks to graduate from
university at skills matter about how to
break into the industry I write my own
content I follow people want github
which is a place with used or that code
yeah I I have to Twitter's I have a
twitter which is full of all the use
useless nonsense that most people have
and my mates and then I have a tech
Twitter that has all the latest news
yeah lots of people lots of candidates
who work at the companies I recruit for
lots of candidates that I might want a
head hunt but I'm you know it's actually
imbibing yourself in the culture rather
than just been I read a website and I
understand because that's not you don't
understand anything that is crusty so
okay just to help me then so there
that everything you just said there yeah
love that what and what has that been an
ongoing process over that the three
years in terms of what you're just
sharing there so you doing talks and all
these things when did you start doing
talk for example was that lie on that
continent a lot quite early on in your
career so I went I basically it was
about six months into the job and we
stopped working with the General
Assembly for this kind of stuff and they
asked if they could have someone sit on
the tech panel and I got to doing I was
too nervous I don't think I can do it a
bit no because I'd only been doing it
six months and you didn't back yourself
I thought well yeah that's what I'm
thinking a lot of people listen go great
get that but there's no way I'm going to
speak in front of these tech people I
look like an absolute nineties okay so
so the tech that's in fairness the tech
thing was more about how do you break it
to the industry so his presence it was
more recruitment than tech okay but my
director did it instead and I sat and I
watched and afterwards I went this is
just all recruitment like you see that
you think about how much you recruit
like you know the 10,000 hour theory
right yeah way to do something 10,000
hours you're gonna be an expert and you
think about how often you sound like you
from the start you might be doing a 12
hour a day maybe less but let's rough it
at 50 hour a week and you know you've
already done a hundred weeks when a
hundred hours by the time you've been
there a month mmm you know you'd be
there 10 months you've done it a
thousand hours you're one-tenth of the
way to being an X when I look at ya and
you think about how much time you
actually put into it you will not if you
try and do your best at your job there
is no way you won't be credible to speak
about it in six months to a year yeah
you might not be perfect but you'll have
something there that you can really like
that okay so and but yeah just to help
me then cuz I'd really like to go into
that because I think that's really
valuable and of I've actually had over
the last couple of episodes actually
where people have ran events or being
involved and doing the things you're
talking about and a lot of it has
actually been in the tech market yeah
well the other go to tech sales so I
think that's really valuable so I guess
what well while we're on it then look
what was the if you continue that what
was the process of you getting to the
point of actually nah don't like that no
that's a bit too much for me I'm not
going to do it to go in there seem what
your boss didn't actually nah
I reckon I could talk about that maybe
two they're now fully blown I'm sure you
do it quite often do a lot or quarterly
or I don't know as much as I can
yeah
like what was that whole process I think
it was I think was honestly just seeing
it firsthand and you you go in initially
being asked to do it anything what
horrible questions are they gonna ask me
you think they're gonna come up with
something so I overcomplicated that
you've never heard before but how often
do we say the recruitment simple you
know it's it's them it's the most simple
thing in the world in so many ways that
these people were just asking you know
how could you help them get a job and if
you've been doing the job six months and
you can't answer that then there's
something really going wrong and it was
more about yeah just seeing it firsthand
and seeing you know what kind of
questions do these people actually ask
and suddenly go I actually know these
answers because I do it all day every
day for the last six months of my life
and then eventually yeah as I say it
becomes a confidence thing of you know
backing yourself to an extent yeah I'm
being well I can't help people but you
have to you have to own it you can't
just do it because your director tells
you
may for sure bill more money which I
think is the big problem for most people
is they're told go get yourself a
Twitter and I think you're gonna die
when you and all they do is post job ads
on it yeah I'm not actually tweet or
interact with anyone yeah and you know
that's the big difference right you
can't just do it for the sake of doing
it because you it won't just work like
that you have to be genuine not honest a
minute I think I think I absolutely love
the way that you've approached that and
again I know we were laughing and joking
before we went on but I think generally
think and look sort of the age group
that you're in you're slightly younger
than me and these things a large
anything I'd like to think that because
I mean more and more recruiters actually
do generally trying to give themselves
an industry they'll quit specifically
Tech and I think I think the fact I
think to round that off I think that for
any recruiters listening if listen Jack
they're off so you built more confidence
in what you do you're not shy to say
actually I am recruited but ultimately
the people that you serve in your market
you need to really believe that you can
serve them yeah and I think obviously
recruiters are in such a great position
to give tons and heaps of value to
software engineers or to people because
you will be very well informed of the
best projects out there the best
companies out there they're companies
that are enabling and software engineers
to upskill themselves or wherever it may
be but ultimately that's that's what
you've got better
being confident actually I'm very
well-informed to let every single know
every single person know in this room
there yeah if they do need help at some
point I can't help them but this is the
value I bring I'm not here because I can
write code and I'm better than you at
that it's actually look I'm here and I
can add value and actually back yourself
to do that I think I love that the first
thing I say one of the first thing I'd
always say hello in a PDA in a beanie
cool one of the things I always say to
someone is you know I'm not a tech
specialist I'm not a front-end
specialist I can't write code but you're
not hiring me for that what I back
myself in is being an expert a genuine
expert in the front-end market I can
tell you what's going on who's moving
where why people are going what's the
UPS what's the downs and if you want and
that's the value you get from me I'm not
a CV Factory and also in tech if you
expect someone to be a CV factory you're
gonna be sorely disappointed because
there's not enough candidates out there
so you have to add value in the right
ways and it's about saying look these
amount of people I reached out to this
is why people were interested this were
people weren't interested this is where
all your people that you want to hire
this is where they're actually going mmm
this is the 20 grand more they're paying
you are which is always the class a lot
off unless we can mate so the question
that everyone's probably thinking right
now mate yes a perm huh well I'm
thinking everyone's listings gone yeah
sounds great how does that make me more
money Jack how does it make me more
money
I don't do any Biddy okay everything is
by referral interesting because whether
that's people that I and that's been
just let should be honestly that's been
over time right yeah yeah yeah
what period would you say no you really
started seeing the traction of
everything you've listed there two years
maybe last two years you've had what a
solid consistent amount of referrals of
what we're talking jobs were talking
candidates by I could tell you actually
it was June so I started into the
September before and it was June so had
been 10 months was when I started
getting referrals for jobs
multiple referrals for jobs in the same
month really yeah
and that was through I had a slack
community as well well I'm really
rubbish I now so don't let's not pretend
it's not a sell I did really badly with
it I saw
die yeah it's something that III had one
that died I did know called recruiter
revolution my mother from mine was
called decoding your future I've got 40
people in there and then I was like [ __ ]
I'm gonna have to pipe message like in
this group consistently for this to be
to work and live and breathe yeah so
yeah it's something that actually if
you're thinking of doing that don't
underestimate that you are gonna have
you're gonna have to generate the
conversation yeah in that early on
otherwise it's gonna die mom was like
mom was okay I was like 200 people in it
which I thought was decent but yeah and
that stage of my career I still was
someone who had to resource 80% their
time to get any success so I couldn't
then stripped 10% that way to be like
saying to my director my MD my magic
time way I'm just messaging my mates on
slap PA and they'll be like how does
this translate to money I'm like because
I'm nice right how does it make you
money
yes oh you send you get sort of the mana
referrals yeah so months in yeah because
there are so many people out there that
don't even bother to try and do the
right things as long as you show an are
genuine about it and you're not just
doing it because you've been told to
then good things will come of it and
that's a nasty thing you have to be
someone who genuinely cares and is
genuinely trying and isn't just doing it
in a cheesy smarmy way to try and pick
up leads you know I never spoke about
jobs in that group I never to people but
people start being open to be like oh
yeah I actually interviewed here
recently and I never went and picked up
on it was like oh I got a lead from
soand you know you have to be legit
right you know it's like if a client
gives you information about you know
people they recently interviewed to be
like this is the kind of stand-up we're
looking for you can't then go to those
candidates and be like oh I know you
recently interviewed I've got a similar
job because you lose trust with the can
trust with the client you lose all
credibility you know you're not if
you're only I'm gonna say again if
you're only in this job to chase money
you're doing it the wrong way you have
to care about the people and you have to
care about what you do here money is
your motivator but you also have to have
another reason to get up in the morning
because the money's not running you
won't come into work right yeah so I
think yeah in terms of the way it works
is you know it's what do these people
say then so like you
to categorically go that's happened
because of this where people calling you
or message you going jack on this this
company is recruiting and they've said
Oh Kjetil they're reaching action gun
Jack I saw you at the Assembly or
whatever do you get what I mean what no
yeah
how what are they saying saying she's
you go WOW okay this is working whatever
so there's been times and I've been
maybe too harsh and salesy with it like
there was someone I met at the General
Assembly and I was like are you free to
grab a coffee often and I was like are
you getting on with home which I think
was maybe a bit too salesy okay no other
people would actually disagree yeah but
you know you'd can't I invited them
there to help fill a spot yeah they said
I would if you know anyone jump in I
said oh I'll invite this person and
afterwards I spoke to him but maybe I
should have left it I think you know
there are other jobs out there you don't
have to worry they take it the wrong way
no they gate they hope they gave me a
job oh then they never came back to me
after that because I think I was too
soon with the what you think yeah
they're in their shoes oh my god Jack
just invite me to get me in a corner
yeah yeah and I hadn't I done actually
to help the General Assembly yeah but in
the end I had ended up doing something
that sort of went against my general
Creed because I was like oh I should do
it yeah then I won't do it yeah and I
think there's also there have been time
like the slack group for example people
were messaging me directly why slack
being like can you help us out or
someone that I'd never spoken to before
I basically got people on my slack by
sending a spam through the database to
everyone been like hey sorry this is a
spam join this group if you want I'm not
posting jobs it's just genuine community
because they aim for it the angle was
sort of putting mentors with juniors
young gap and then people had never
spoken to you before they just happen to
be on our system then messaging me on
LinkedIn you know how can you help his
roles but that was a direct impact yeah
I think the more you do that kind of
stuff the more people realize that you
are genuine and you're not just yeah but
you have to keep doing it you can't just
start no it doesn't it doesn't yes oh
it's like building recruitment desk
isn't it yes not as continuous its
consistency its resilience it's and I
guess you just to round them off then
and then we'll sort of track back but
may often that often that's class I love
them the way they approach that and I
think and just to run them off I think
then how like I'm thinking again
people listening if I'm like you said if
I'm if I'm listening right now and I'm
gonna say someone manager tomorrow right
or listen to this podcast I'm gonna
start a slack channel or whatever there
is that internal selling that you've got
to do to say well no actually this is
worth money or whatever so I've got my
own opinion on how you can sort of make
sure that every single person in that
office knows when your team knows that
you've got big win or whatever like what
what did you do to sell internally to
sort of make sure that people perceive
what you were doing is fruitful and it
is generating billing do not I mean yeah
I don't think anyone thinks I do any
work I'm see when I do a deal they're
like how really when I pick up a client
they're like how really yeah and that
that's had you not said so for me my
advice would be because I speak I speak
this one this is my huffing like
personal branding might say and that's
pretty much what what you're doing
through different strategic and smart
ways but for me my advice is always if
you're a recruiter right now and you're
like right okay so I'm gonna continue
doing what I need to do find wise
meetings building real relationship yeah
but I'm now gonna spend on a half an
hour a day to build a slack channel to
create content or whatever if you get a
win off that everyone needs to know
about it in my opinion about it do you
not I mean no that's the thing I'm far
too egotistical to not let people know
about it yeah so they will find out but
like on a day-to-day they don't see it
happening as 1 million that's fair
they'll be like oh what's he been doing
all day he's not picked up the phone
once but I'm about to bring Ryan content
and then I'll release the content and a
client will come to me and say hey just
saw your post about this can you help us
with this role fair enough and then I go
haha everyone you thought I wasn't doing
any work ya know that now I appreciate
that I think what all I'd say is if if
you were listening right now and you
probably could you may not be able to
get away with that because some way with
that I'm saying if someone could if you
did AB LinkedIn post and you've got a
chronic come to you and you registered
jobs or just even a small win that's
what I used to do in your fitness I was
an office of eight people and I was the
widow in the office creating content and
only managed to personal read one other
person to do it with me yeah like if I
made a BD corner go and then go he's
your man so you're video or I'll go to
networking event and someone come up to
me I am making every single person know
because I mean look we're competitive
we're competitive right and all this
stuff and he's doing no work you're not
I'm in so that would be my advice for
people listening is if you do want to
feel a listeners shotgun Wow okay that
is interesting maybe I should try stuff
blah blah blah if you can't get if you
do have a relationship way you can have
that communication when I land in and
welcome you sit in it slightly
differently blah blah but if you do need
to do a bit of selling internally then
make sure everyone celebrate your wins
basically is what I'm trying to say in
short I think the other thing as well
there's two things here is one is that
my director and I have got completely
different ideas about how or at least
when I start about how to do recruitment
yeah and the different and he would say
you know do the classic way which is
fine it works but for me I didn't get it
it didn't work for me yeah and he was
less keen to listen to me when I hadn't
got any experience or any wins out of it
but eventually over time you know he's
fine with it because he knows that it
brings success eventually yeah but I
think it was also there had to be the
buildup and then he was like oh he
actually does pickup grinds off doing
this oh he actually does get wins out of
this but for me my actual advice would
be you know I didn't do it all during
working hours this is like the added
extras that Gabe are you know if I don't
think anyone will get away with between
8:30 and 6 being on slack just sitting
there writing blogs people will be like
what are you doing like some like
especially if you're not like well over
target or whatever which most people
were the early stage their career won't
be yeah you know you that's when you do
give your extra mile and you stay an
hour late in your write blog and then
you post it see the likes and the views
yeah I mean as I've shown you before we
went on here like it's it's got to be
both for me I know it's you know you've
you've got your own little lane and it's
working but for me it's got to be it's
got to be combined and both and the aim
and the intention is the blog the slack
that the day is going to enable the when
you do reach out to that person when you
do ask that person for a coffee
hopefully there's stuff that you have
been doing does brain trust and
credibility there yeah absolutely
enables you to hopefully have more
fruitful conversations before Tom down
the road is a tech recruiter who's
calling someone for the first time send
you on a coffee mate and I'm a recruiter
blah blah blah as opposed to Jack who's
at the assembly that you go I'm in
that's the whole game I think I'm in
more when you start doing and you have
to
that battle internally yeah you know if
you are doing out of hours and it's
getting success and then they can't
fight back if you do then go do it into
in your normal hours and be like this
was more successful for me then you're
sitting there on the phone
hitting gatekeepers for an hour yeah if
that makes sense yeah and I'll get that
call me I enjoyed that we're not for the
little tangent that's good so I guess
it's a first in recruitment you thought
he wasn't that great
no right and I guess it's all make sense
that I guess if people around you
typically yeah just using traditional
methods and these things so I guess
first how did you do in your first year
then did you build more than 24k yeah
how much do you build mate I told you
all right done here 56 56 okay cool and
then did you see them when did you show
six months in you again sorry 10 months
in you get more referrals but just to
give me a bit of context then did you
when was the jewel desk when did you do
about that I'd your desk up until maybe
a year ago really yeah okay cool and
then what have you always done perdóname
perm or is it it is predominantly perm
so I suppose just give an idea where
Redcats at is we've had more official
contract desks in the past yeah past but
when I joined we didn't really have one
it was mostly people jewel desk in
around a year ago we started building
out contract division yeah totally again
so it was around year ago that I started
passing my contract rolls over to that
desk yeah and but beforehand we didn't
have enough people headhunting and going
after those roles specifically yeah it
was more dedicated resource to it yeah
then they shared resource a lot oh yeah
one day of my time because you've got
one requirement coming in every now and
then yeah so that was fine fairs what
was a what went on in those first twelve
months man besides you sort of not back
in yourself and seemed like that was
obviously you're building that
confidence but what what what went on
looking back right what did you learn
what went on the nose on those first
twelve months when they're pretty grim
though they were though so people always
say they recruit you first saw Munson
recruitment the hardest thing you ever
do you I really disagree okay why
because there are so many harder things
in life than you your day-to-day job and
if it is that hard then quit
right like it's important to enjoy your
job there are so many more important
things in life and for me yeah it was
tough but I also enjoyed it so it wasn't
that tough because I'd enjoyed getting
up and facing the challenge I don't
think it was as hard as I was expecting
it to be I don't think there was one
many late nights as I expected there to
be hmm I think you overcome an initial
hump and once you overcome that hump and
things start clicking I think it's like
anything you know every six months
you're like what did I know that many
months ago things were really clicked
now then another six months you go what
did I know then things and it happens
over and over every six months you think
something news clicks and it's just
because you're still learning and I'm
still learning now obviously I'm not
that long yes I squat but what you're
talking about there's a mindset yeah
perspective hmm where did that come from
Ida sporting background as I mentioned
earlier so that was quite helpful
because they you are right because I
agree it's like I think that's some
really sound advice right obviously
you're six months in 12 months in year
and a half in whatever and you having a
dreadful three months in a row or
whatever it's very quick it's very quick
to forget what where you where you was
to go I mean yeah so that I think that
that's really good advice and and and
people gave that advice before but I
guess yeah did that did you naturally
cultivate that perspective did that just
was it just through your life
experiences and background or cants hair
that sound like cheesy give me the
cheese must I believe in Quinn really if
there's a wall you've got to try it
right and I think you don't believe in
quitting I just don't know you because
what's the point
mmm I think I think there's been too
many times in my life when I've chosen
to quit University is great I was so
lazy yeah one of my good mates he's we
say all the time is so funny I went from
being the laziest [ __ ] at uni it
hadn't nothing like I had so few contact
hours compared to everyone else that I
would come home and sitting on so free
and thereõs they come I'd come back I
was later after a whole day at uni and
I'd be in the same place with just a new
bag Jesus Christ
whereas now I've got like a really
strong work ethic and I think that hat
that had to be bedded into me a little
bit
and I think but I think eventually you
do have to realize that you know you're
working for yourself to an extent yeah I
think once you get over there oh I'm
being told what to do and I'm being told
why I'm doing it once you get over that
you just billing money too so you can
stay in a job run then I'm billing money
to make myself money mm-hmm I think
that's a bit of a switch in your mindset
as well and that's a good thing too
that's a good thing because then you say
why am i doing this task is really
really hard and you go why I'm doing it
all for me I'm doing it so that I can
benefit so I can grow and so I can be
better as a person yeah so it's all you
saying there you yeah you made it bigger
than ah this is my target and okay yeah
but the target 100 200 20k or whatever
that you're saying well actually when
you really think about that yeah I'm
doing this really challenging thing
which I'm finding really difficult
because it's gonna enable me to buy a
house or yeah absolutely you can't get
to that I think targets are superficial
to an extent because some businesses do
just make them up don't they it's making
my flash rip and a red cat we are quite
structured with how we do it but also
for me I'm not I'm never aiming for
target I'm aiming for fully ground above
target because I'm not ever settling for
just what's fine and I think again the
university never gives up what I was
just settling for 2-1 I was happy with
it I knew I was gonna get it leave it
fine but I've in it I don't ever want to
settle for just you know what's
acceptable I mean I know that most
agencies actually being above 80 percent
or similar you know that's still pretty
decent for lots of people no I don't see
it that way a hundred percent is my base
limit I don't ever want to be below that
if I'm below that I'm failing then if
you're there then you're quite high
standards for yourself yeah absolutely
and I think if you don't have high
standards you don't progress
yeah I agree I'm Gracie and before we
move on then what would you if you were
to go back first year in recruitment
yeah probably you do anything
differently talk back bless oh yeah I
talk back so much and I still do it now
I thought I was better so what you're
saying there is you asked a question and
you want to the question nose in someone
gives me advice I might know oh sorry
I'm sorry okay as in law I'll give back
check your attitude really which is
sometimes
well obviously making your [ __ ] 2-1
English limping silver tongue sometimes
sometimes I think it was Brett sometimes
it was necessary from my perspective is
in you know I think this is works for me
let it work for me and sometimes those
things did work but 90% of the time I
should have just listened and tried in
and they were from from more experienced
people around much more experience
appear and I fought I knew better and I
ops II did not because I'm I was in the
salesman I wasn't a good recruiter yet
so what who was I to talk it yeah by
4kids that's good advice man I
appreciate that
yeah listen to the people that have been
in for 500 grand a year not me who's
done six no I think that's and one of
the one of the episodes I asked them an
agency owner they're the two
characteristics that he looks for in the
new hire and he said the two
characteristics that he always looks for
is humility
and having a growth mindset yeah I
thought I was wicked but that's what
you're talking about there is if you had
a bit more humility early on there
would've been the less bat.chat and less
energy on my action I know what I'm
doing you need to do one yeah I'm more
of what actually let's actually try that
and that might have enabled you to fail
a bit more quicker or try the new thing
which would have got you to where you
wanted to get to a bit quicker yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely that how did
how did you call of it how did that
happen from that for you to listen more
then when I started doing things my way
and sometimes it didn't work or
sometimes or when it was more like
you're doing it or you're in trouble and
I'd do it and it works and I got a ho
I made it work yeah just listening you
know it's weird because internally I
think I'm quite humble because I have
high standards on myself I'm never and
I'm never happy with where I'm at
whereas externally I'm like super
egotistical and arrogant whatever and
all my friends like you ain't just such
a big head mmm but that's because I
think it's like an element of I need to
talk myself up externally otherwise I'm
like I'm not doing well enough yeah
so for me like I say you know 100
percent is never okay I have to be high
I've got those high standards yeah which
is the growth mentality I suppose an
internal internally and like on a
one-to-one basis I feel I couldn't be
quite humble and accept him where I'm at
mmm big externally I I'm just such a
loudmouth it makes it really awful yeah
it is my bad but everyone's
he's useful when you're in a recruitment
office yeah cool man
it's a year to talk to me a bit about
that then so obviously yeah by this
point you again a few more referrals so
I guess by this point are you
slowly but surely building your desk
you're getting you're winning more so by
this point you're building a jet prior
recruitment business right a machine
yeah yeah yeah - is it was good because
I think that was the first time when I
was like I feel like I'm flying a bit
really yeah that I'm like putting away
you know I thought big numbers at least
have really start to build some
confidence yeah and I mean I had the
help of a contract book as well okay
which I which I don't have now because
obviously that's moved over if it
obviously that's not just I'm assuming
that just didn't land on your lap I had
to make the placements so yeah yeah AB
see but I think there's like an element
of in my head I was like I'm so perma
critter so I wasn't doing enough to
justify if that makes sense I still want
to do more perm whereas where I'm at now
is like I've done I'm making up I'm
still doing more numbers but without the
contract yeah okay so I've actually
grown quite a lot in terms that perms
yeah yeah okay fair enough so I guess
before we talk about the growth there
then just quickly out of complete
curiosity think of thinking of people
listen and don't know how many people
listen dude your desk don't know how
common that is in today today I don't
think I hear it too much but it's
definitely still here at like what's
your advice there then now you're just
solely on perm like how did you get
better at the juggling act I'm assuming
because was you was you when you was
doing contract was it typically working
with businesses that you were to do poem
with yeah sorry oh I'm in so we I have
one specific project I had a couple
other runners that went out through the
year by one specific big project that
took in a lot a lot of Billings she had
one what couple of key accounts it was
just one account really one and you it
did you enough so it was a split with my
manager she'd been working with the
account for a while and what happened
was they basically had
three tech roles that have been out to
agencies for a very long time they can
fill any of them it was three roles I
thought all of them even though they'd
had two months headstart no okay that's
great she's nine yeah we want more
people like that get me on the PSL yeah
that was exactly it we did add one of
roles here and there with um she known
him for years but they never were like
we're gonna give you lots of roles
suddenly they gave us these three roles
I filled them all we're celebrating you
know we've done really really well and
it's something they were like hey look
we've got a massive big project that
needs those exact same people on the
contract we're gonna give it to you
fully exclusively managed service you're
gonna help us out Bosch yeah so we
worked on that together that's Fran and
we got a big contract bit from that and
that was that was really helpful for me
it's like a helping hand because I think
the difficulties one of the big
difficulties for all recruiters at any
level with consistency is yeah yeah
making sure you're as good as your last
their last mountain yeah making sure
you're running through money each month
so for me the idea that I've got a
contract with it's making me good amount
of money
I'm not blank in a month you know yeah
you've gone that looked in for those
tips up or whatever exactly is
guaranteed you're gonna pull in circa
this amount of money as long as those
contractors downside which they did and
it was just a case of I've got a comfort
blanket now you know the second year was
like okay you got an actual real proper
target now mmm how are you gonna beat it
and I thought well I've got a comfort
blanket that's gonna help me out I don't
have to sit there and be worried about
me like I'm below target you know what
someone's gonna cover me for a good
chunk of that so would you say that was
a positive or a negative massive
positive yeah yeah it was super helpful
I think the difficulty is for lots of
people that were chore desk is they're
still expected to go pick up contracts
and like go actively looking for and
getting more projects and I think that's
really difficult to work alongside a
parent desk personally yeah if you've
got a resource for their parent jobs the
resources is not the problem is its
contract you know you can find people in
a day or two yeah it's the actual going
going out to find those companies find
those projects get the rolls on that's
really tricky unless you've got either a
a
a Bitcoin that I was contracts you've
got a really firm relationship with and
you make it quite clear you can do
contract or B you're actively going out
to find them most contractors both most
contractors will spend like 80 percent
their time doing BD really you can't
then take that and put it on a permit
consult as well and be like are you
beating for both they need to have a bit
more of a structured goal about are you
building up a book or a pen money on the
board mmm that makes sense yeah that
make sense I think it's really I think
it's really hard to do that but how did
you go about it then like I say it was
more we worked at Jewel desk as and when
the roles were given to us okay fair is
fair so he had two accounts that were
going to throw us the Rutles then we
worked them and in that case it was a
huge project so that made sense but we
never went out and looked for it okay
enough where and you've identified that
actually that is where the challenge
would come yeah yeah okay so then that's
what the interest in May and then I
guess obviously in in this obviously
second year how obvious Lee now you just
in perm so how long have you just done
perm for just so just every year just
over you know so that's where you really
start to pick up and all right so I
guess what how was you slowly a bit
surely building that perm side then how
would you how would you sort of
approaching that I don't I don't think
there's anything different than the
standard answers of just reaching out to
right-handers putting in the right time
as I say I've got a lot of time to do my
sourcing because I don't spend a lot of
time doing BD and that makes a life my
life a lot easier because I don't think
there's much nuance in I mean there is a
lot of nuance to that market in about
knowing we're talking about buying the
rest of it is the same amount of know
who you're looking for approach them in
the right way
approach them tactfully and reach out to
the right number of people hmm and then
you'll get those good candidates come
through the door mmm
and then it helps if you are known it
helps if you do the right things in the
background like content and
presentations and whatnot but in the end
I don't think there's any more advice I
can give to actually building out the
perm desk you know other than just be
strict with your processes to yourself
and keep affirm or keep firm
organization on what you're doing so you
have a track of what you've done and
when basically I think that's well in
that and I appreciate that so I guess
just to sort of give some context then
so from from what you were saying
earlier your Billings went in the
positive direction right they did or
they did and they've continued to yeah
yeah so what so what's been your best
year so far today I mean it's only two
full years so far yes I did 186 last
year one exit yeah and then you and then
you've already like you're well on the
verge to hopefully I'm on 150 so far
this year and what's the financial year
like January to December yeah oh that's
exciting
yeah - wanna break that 200k mark yeah
that's the aims is that your standard
like I've got a bread that 200 came up
yeah pretty much
really yeah so what would you say then
and what what really wanna what I've
into a couple of things but life think
thinking about that was there any key
elements do you think that really
contributed you to absolutely smash in
that first year besides I'll see you
having a lot more repetition of what
you're doing and all those things like
do you think that you put down would you
put that down to anything in particular
or not really no not really I think I
just answered your question yeah no no
really I think there's there's a few
elements here and there that I find
important that things set me apart for
those kinds of things I think one is
about sourcing properly and that's been
understanding how to sort people that's
not just going for a list on LinkedIn if
you were tarik return you only use
LinkedIn then quit there was a we went
to a talent for talent pool do meet ups
yeah we went to their first one me and a
few of the teams in October I think it
was and they were going over tech
sourcing and they did like a poll on how
many people were using certain tools
github the one I mentioned earlier which
is I use it all day every day is it's my
second most important or after LinkedIn
if you don't know get hub know get hump
they asked they asked people who are
coming they did like a hundred agency
recruiters or something and they asked
how many of them use github and it was
zero percent yeah and that's the that's
my competition missing my second most
important tool so when people say what
am I missing to smash it I think you're
missing
and justjust give some contacts for
everyone always github github is
basically where you store your code if
you're a company or a developer side
projects or sometimes big projects
they're actually commercially vibe like
out there okay so what what why is that
you want so how that so surely that's a
whole different game to approach people
in there surely yeah but it's more a
case of if you put your projects on
there you are and you're more able to
determine are they right for this role
if someone's like fer for argument's
sake a JavaScript developer but they
have done a few recent projects in go so
sorry just help me out here
yeah you have access to people to
portfolios it's basically portfolio yeah
yes okay that makes it yeah yeah sorry
that was much easier way to phrase it
yeah but its way it's where people put
their side projects this was where they
all so it can showcase their skills
which which makes them presentable to
potential businesses to win to get jobs
that but for some people it's like the
Notes app on your iPhone like it's just
little shoe boot scribbles they've done
on the spare time to see if something
works right but even so it's about
knowing what someone's interested in um
and not in like a stalkers raela I know
where you're interesting it's more like
I've actually gone out of my way to see
what you're interested in mmm I don't
put a CV forward unless table looks
their github first to see what's going
on really yeah because okay for a start
if someone tells me oh I'm not actively
looking I'm putting this CV together for
you and you go in there github and their
first thing on there is a thing called
CV and it was dated two weeks ago and it
was what they've just sent you and I go
hey bud why are you already a CV and
they're like oh yeah there are these
other roles that I'm interviewing with
you know it's like it's it's an insight
into the candidate into more detail
there are most recruiters as we've said
0% of agency recruiters that talent for
estimating don't use it and for me it's
my number one tool - yeah so there's
that there's other things like
understanding how to x-ray search
properly so you can get to the bottom of
things you need to do there's like
automating your Dave I linked in with
safe searches and stuff like that so
first thing I'm really the first one in
the office at a everyday uh normally
open
I come in go and save searches flick
through people that open your chin he's
by the time people were rolling in at
9:00 I've already hit 50 candidates
there are open your chin who doesn't
love that man anything so yeah I guess
I'm saying like there's nothing more you
can do but I think there's loads you can
do and I'm just being maybe a bit too
hmm
concise about it I think maybe he'll be
in we did never our to talk about yeah
no no I think in and I'll be honest with
you mate so one of the I think I work
with to recruit is the operate and tech
market and that's where I heard a get
huh yeah
so I guess I know we're sort of really
leaning into a real niche here but I
mean it's a very popular market and
might be interesting to people but in
like two or three points if I'm a 10
recruit listen right now don't have to
give away all your secrets but it's
trying to finger people listening like
what's like for an absolute github
rookie how should a recruiter attempt to
use this tool instead of just looking
like an absolute clunker and using it in
the wrong way or whatever there's any
sort of one or two tip so you go right
don't do this or you approach it using
it this way whatever so there reap so
they're repositories which is where they
store their code it will list what tech
is used for each project okay just have
a flick through the most recent ones and
you can see what they're using up to
date in their most recent roles yeah the
most recent spare time you know there
are some people that get up about really
old-school tech they haven't used them
five years and you can see that on their
github yeah okay that's right the bottom
there's watched it recruiters a lot
trying to talk some about something that
I did yeah yeah and also if you have a
role that's got a really neat ekend you
can find something's played around in
their spare time you can say hey I've
actually got some of my interest you
they're like do not thank the Lord
someone's at the time because everyone
give you some credibility in some trust
yeah absolutely secondly secondly I'm be
giving away too much really fair I know
there's there's not there's not that
much to a fair as fair enough
you know people the other thing I'd say
is people often leave their personal
website on their which is another bit of
an insight into the can do well they do
yeah you know they might have you know
they're interested in photography for
example they might travel in again and
giving it again it's giving you that
opportunity to have a unique difference
when you reach now when it's the
candidate you're not just speaking to
them as I hey I've got a job for you
you're interested you can ask them
the stuff you saw on their website and
they go oh this person actually looked
into Mina's approached me for a role
because they think I'm good not because
they've sent out a spam to two hundred
people which is what unfortunately lots
of people do right yeah no I really like
that May so I guess what what I love
about sort of your approach and
everything is 100 percent from what
you're telling me you do approach in a
unique way and you send that approaching
people in the right way and these things
talk to me a bit about that because I
think a lot of people can get some value
out of that like what for in you from
your perspective from jack preijers
recruitment career so far it's clearly
quite different you know I mean for you
what what's the right way there's loads
of stuff that recruits do that I hate
talk to me not telling them who your
client is yeah I Spit wait not tell them
how much you'll pay a bit weird not
telling them about the role until you
get them on the phone yeah that's that's
pretty much it like knew that adults
right yeah if you're sending someone a
cold message you're already on the
backfoot like accept that don't be like
oh yeah I'm not gonna talk to you unless
you unless you speak to me on the phone
so does me like might piss off I'm not
gonna give you half an hour of my time
yeah unless I know it's worth it
another thing and you might describe me
on this on don't put I hope you're
having a nice day I hope you're well
you're right I'll do that with
everything with you see I don't
on a cold message to someone I don't
know because I just want them to know
why I'm reaching out yeah get straight
to the point
yeah but and I know foreplay I used to
disagree with that because we had
someone who came to her we had such an
external woman who used to come help
train us sometimes when we're quite
geniune she was like when I'm on the
phone I never say like how are you she's
I just get straight to the point
yeah on the phone I say how are you so
like we're having a chat yeah yeah nomad
and I normally will tell them what's
happening with me you know normally I
speak to people on the first air tell
them what's you know how we did in
five-a-side a lunchtime yeah I think I
think you know the whole sort of like I
hope you're having a really nice day
from a cold message to like 100
candidates in a day like you don't care
mmm stop pretending you care like how
many people actually send that and
they're like hot you know what I really
hope judy is having a nice day ya know
no one does I'd be honest with why you
miss what you ten
I'm saying be honest with while you're
messaging people in my it's come back to
you if you say I'm recruiting for X
company I think you look really good
because they're looking for this and
you've you're a good match they're gonna
pay you this much you know they're nice
people it's gonna be an interesting
opportunity if you're open if you're not
sorry for annoying you see you later hmm
you know you have to acknowledge that
you're speaking to people coldly and
that you are on the backfoot because
there's also a million other
opportunities come in their way from
other really cool companies that might
pay the same or be more interesting ah
yeah and if there's if I don't know them
you know if it's fully cold they might
be like I'm thinking a move into another
country or yeah I'm gonna I'm not
interested in this specific industry
like you have to be upfront because do
you want to waste your own time speaking
someone twenty minutes now like oh is
this in London to get to the porno
interested like be straightforward like
we asked as much as I said I'm not sales
e it is sales descent isn't yeah for
sure it's like getting straight to the
point just going straight to the point
as to how you're hoping it can help them
can you solve like do that kind of how
many challenges and problems it you
might be able to solve just getting
straight to the point basically yeah and
there's another pet peeve I have and
it's people gonna disagree me on this
song for sure
is when you send out lots of messages
about one role and then be like there's
some ways it when you're sending out
messages to lots of people and you want
lots of similar people for lots of
different roles actually putting like
three or four different roles in the
same message well I'm confused so I'm
recruiting fur company ABCD yeah they
all one on the same person they all want
candidate X yeah and I go to each
candidate X saying I've got roles at
ABCD that you all look good for here's
each role because then they're like you
may as well send them a spam message
yeah why would you be like you haven't
made it like bespoke to that person
there's an element of making it bespoke
and also being like you're just being
lazy yeah like if they come back and
they reject your message come back and
be like hey no worries company a is not
good for you I do actually accrue for
BCD that would be good don't want to
waste your time so true you know I think
that's more important I think there's an
element of laziness just trying to shove
everything together yeah I'm just trying
to reach the same candidates for the
same sort of things it's like yeah but
you're wasting everyone's time at the
same time because they're not gonna
that's that message you've wasted two
hours a day mm-hmm and I think that like
I always preach quality over quantity
all the time no kpi's of KPS sake
the only KPI is that I care about our
TVs to interview ratio yeah interview
for anyone to interview tea does that
turn to offer is there money on the
board I don't care about you know I
generally don't care about how many TVs
I get out of the door as long as I know
I've covered enough and I've got good
people mmm because I know they'll
convert to interview I think you know I
think my CV to infest interview ratio at
the moment one to one point two or
something like that
yes but that's far more important to me
yeah of course then just trying to
shortcut okay I think and then I think
that ties into everything we talked
about earlier as to the insights you're
going through competitors and how
they're trying to understand the people
that they're hoping to help and these
things right yeah absolutely
yeah so I guess does this translate into
the business development side then like
you quiet is that how you approach the
business developments on in terms of the
the direct approach or are you very
reliant on what's coming to you and the
referrals if so that's cool I do a bit
of both so like when I say I do BDS more
if I can do I know is looking or a
candidate I've got them well from the
start is looking actively and I say hey
how are you getting on do you want
actually real help or a sort of happy
where you are going through recruiters
or or applications if they want help
then it's a case of let's go get a beer
let's talk about where you want to work
on what you want from this role hmm I'm
gonna give you ten options I'm gonna go
through a companies that I think would
be good for you I'm gonna give you ten
options because you know what you want
but I know the market yeah I know what
companies Mike that's all you're
well-informed about give them those
companies and say pick free and I'll go
introduce you to them and also write me
something about each company once you've
had a look at it so when you actually
given up getting to do some work only
given an approach to an internal I do
most of my approaches to internal
recruiters as well really cuz I think
most people consider an approach to a
hiring manager either a wasting a hiring
managers time because they don't have
then are the ones that deal with
agencies aren't on a PSO yeah or they
don't care where the CVS come from they
just review the CVS and be you don't I
think most internal courtesy is going
behind their back as well you you want
champing the internal cruising be on
their side I'm working that way on a
day-to-day I'd be working with the
internal recruit it's not the home
manager really so who do I want the
relationship with who's got that who's
gonna help me open up the business work
on other roles when I go to meet the
company chances are me the high manager
for half an hour talk about the role and
what they need but I'm gonna be
chit-chatting with the the the internal
critter you know they're the ones you
get to know the hiring manager there or
not as much as I can yeah yeah of course
idea I think that's important to you and
there's lots of companies where I've got
a very open relationship with the high
managers but it's never like to go
behind the internal yeah that is assert
them and then you make sure that you're
not perceived that way yeah and that's
why I want my first approach to be sort
of hey look I've gone to you because I
don't want to be that know that and
again you're being direct about that
yeah and it's about being honest from
day one so they know where they're
getting from me and I say hey look I
reached out to this candidate I know
them really really well they're
interested in in moving on they're
interested in you this company in this
company here's what they said about you
this is what I know about them and what
they've been doing I think it's a really
good match what you've been up to and I
suggested it to him do you fancy a chat
and speaking to the candidate in more
detail etc and it's a very it's a very
different approach from saying I spoke
to a candidate they're good I've got a
CV now I'm gonna send it to 50 hiring
managers in a day might get a bite back
and then how many times do either a not
get a bite back begets hard to go away
or see the candidate in two months is
working for that and you go ah I wish I
hadn't done that for me that that's like
my ideal BD approach other than
referrals and now I make thanks for
bringing that down I think I know in
your word you mace
that may sound like basic and just like
simple but that that generally is the
most common question I get asked to ask
people but base development I think
that's that's really interesting how you
break that down so I guess as we wrap up
mate spoke for an hour already
sorry about that minute as we wrap up I
guess just few final things I wanted to
get and your perspective of is I think
yeah obviously went in quite early in
terms of how you've approached
recruitment differently obviously let
you know that that's something that I'm
obviously shoot advocate for so I guess
how how have you continued
how have you continued to make sure that
you give that enough time because I
think a lot of people the biggest
challenges that I hear from people from
recruiters that might be listening to
this going right okay
heard he sham bang on about his personal
brown thing and obviously Jax just
talked about how he's got involved it
and embedded industry in these things
most common challenges are here is I
don't have enough time Hisham right
second one is I have no idea what to
talk about so it's interesting you say
that I was gonna be my answer I don't
write content unless I have something to
talk about okay because how often do you
see content from recruiters recruitment
agencies just trash you have no interest
in reading here's my top ten interview
tips and it's like dress smart yeah well
done chat if I see an interesting
article that I want to bounce off if
there's you know there's one I've done
there's an article I've actually done
twice that was about a survey for
developers by Stack Overflow which is a
sort of a developer's website where you
get answer questions and answers if you
struggling with something you know can
you help me out at forum and they do a
developer survey every year and I write
about insights from that or we did one
where we did insights on the placements
we've done and the candidates and the
Seavey's we've sent so we could talk
about what the market is as a talent
pool yeah you know what the diversity
split is what our diversity help is I
write about that if there's nothing to
write about
don't people disagree with this though
right because people like you should
force the content out and keep it
regular and then you get engagement but
for me I care more about making sure
that content I put out is really good
for me
you know if someone does ask I'm not
like oh that that was trash yes read
that I want someone to say oh that was
actually really really good and really
useful when I do get people say to me I
actually read your article like a year
ago yeah and I remember it yeah that was
good and is that an article decision or
LinkedIn profile yeah yeah so they're
all salma LinkedIn I've got a medium as
well I post on Twitter personal LinkedIn
they get shared on the Redcat page as
well if I read Katz medium page as well
so it helps generate sort of genuine
content that isn't just like yeah oh I
think I should put something out now
because I think you know January how did
you carve out those ideas then was added
ages conference
for my whole thing is um a lot like a
lot of those things you were talking
about them I'm assuming that you've had
in normal conversations with candidates
and clients in the market a lot of the
time and sometimes what one thing for
example it's more about educating
yourself to an extent as well I treat
them kind of like an essay like I've got
this in my source material Nereus these
are the three things I want to pull from
it and talk about and this one break it
down one thing was about I think it was
in one of the surveys it was 52 percent
of developers didn't have even a
bachelor's degree yeah and how many
times you get a job spec so our
bachelors in computer science physics
maths you think and you speak to a home
and you say can we take that off they're
like no we we're really academic or you
know a really high bar I say okay be
missing 48 percent of the market what's
more important to you a class and they
say is class they say oh no no it's
really important to us okay we'll expect
half the series from us mm-hm because
you've market now what I really like
that you said about that is one you
shared your opinion too because I think
recruiters do way too much we're just
sharing articles and then and any
contacts and start frankly those types
of posts don't reach that many people
anyway so I love the fact that you've
done that and then also again yeah so
you you're then using market knowledge
using real conversations to sort of
formulate what what you decide to talk
about and if you're happy to talk about
it I like that and then how have you
maintained that in your normal week do
you get I mean because again time is an
issue right because you've got your
director going Jack get on the phone
mate cuz like that's a real challenge
right I'm gonna hisham I get it
Jack's talking some sense but I've held
off in that man in my day so how have
you got cuz again being open as always
and with people like that's a constant
challenge for me how do I and I look out
on my diary but sometimes I'll do other
stuff and all these things so it's an
ongoing process which I tell people you
get people at but just to see if there's
any practical advice that you have and
you've been through that how have you
maintained that activity that clearly or
is generating a lot of return for you in
your normal yeah
crewman day I think this is probably
where you'll kill me because I don't
really set aside like a dedicated time
for this more as and when I think is
really the good times do act more in the
moment yeah so like I say when it comes
to the doing the content it's more do I
think this is something that's worth
writing about yeah well I think I think
that's a good question to ask first one
for man I think that's a good quality
question I think in terms of you know I
might pin out a post on LinkedIn for the
LinkedIn sake you know I think we talked
about early just being like these are
the ten jobs yeah not worth it not worth
my time I do a job post you know once
every few weeks it goes into a bit more
detail about the role as I mentioned
earlier you know it's not really content
in the same way I like to spread it
across between an element of doing
panels and presentations you know doing
a bit of writing and when I can and then
also as a part of that going to meet
candidates who aren't experienced and
giving them advice into the market so
that's like paying it forward
yeah paying it forward it's definitely a
big part of why ID and I think if you're
not paying it forward in tech like how
can you prove that you actually care mmm
there's nothing more you can still do I
know that I actually like the fact this
has been quite a tech focus but from
what I understand again working with a
few individuals like a lot of people in
the tech market obviously depends but
I've heard this phrase tech4good
and a lot of people do obviously I've
heard from other people that actually
lot of people in industry are actually
really motivated by trying to make some
sort of positive impact in the world
well obviously not everyone but yeah I
think I think Ted for good is more about
how many tech companies are there in the
world they're just glorified ad revenue
generators ef-s so it's more about and
like oh yeah I'd love to work for Apple
they're so groundbreaking and innovative
but they're so like trying monopolize
all your devices take away your money
like trying to take over your whole life
people actually like I want to give back
and for me it's the same you know I
wonder I don't just it's like I say
money is my motivator but I care about
the people as well and it's why I get up
in the morning so when I say I'm going
to meek and he hasn't got any experience
and you might go why you can't mark him
out - anyways I know but you know it's
about helping it's not even a case of oh
but they might go work for a company and
they can help me get a role later on
it's not about that it's a
just genuinely being a person who has a
skill to help people who need my help
who you know might have been someone
like giving them a good word about me or
something and it's about doing what I
can because you know it's if we're all
part of a community as well you know you
can't claim to be part of the tech
community unless you actually give him
back to it as well yeah otherwise you're
gonna get found out yeah absolutely
yeah you might just claim to be a part
of the tech community if you turn up to
a meet-up in your seat with your
messenger bag on the back of business
cards Popkin yeah yeah yeah leave on
leaving them on the chairs or something
you can't do that it doesn't were like
that yeah I I think I do a split of each
when I can yeah like that I don't and I
think you know it's not an element of I
do a bit each day and that's probably my
downfall mm-hmm is I don't do enough of
that mmm I think we're a comfortable
level right now maybe I could do this
working for those things cool so gets to
Randolph night before and I see what's
what you're excited about what's going
on and then your world
I think will be quite a nice thing to
sort of round off because I know we've
spoken about a lot and you might be
repeating yourself but it's fine I guess
advice for people that are two years
free is in obviously maybe a bit in
terms of how long they've been in there
maybe a bit less than you that I'm very
confident Finkley the message that I get
a lot of these people do operate in the
tech market right so I guess just to
round off everything that we've spoken
about any sort of go-to advice for
someone that maybe it's still at that
100k level in the tech market or is
really struggling to push on or get
their name and their tech market these
things any sort of go-to advice to round
off and this whole sort of conversation
does it have to be sure it doesn't it
doesn't have to be it can be sure I've
got a few thoughts there I've got one if
you're stuck around the haunt UK mark if
it's because you're not trying yeah and
you don't care go do something else yeah
if you I mean as soon if they're
listening to recruitment podcast they
care enough yeah for sure but yeah if
you're stuck 100k mark and you're like
happy on in 30 35 grand a year tell you
something else if you do that in sales
and it's gonna be less stressful and
whatever christmas house mate you know
like over virgin media I think Intel in
terms of advice for people that people
that are caring and are trying and
they're struggling I think for me again
it goes back to that be genuine like be
a real person and be human be human
don't just be a sales generator and
churning things in and out you know mere
human
and people buy off humans I think one
thing I was going to say earlier was you
know you look at the graphs of how
people move from one company to another
in tech and it's like an overwhelming
amount are through friends and referrals
from friends really and if you stop
being that salesy recruiter who is
always just hammering you and isn't
friendly and isn't nice and you can't
get on with you know they're not gonna
go by you if you are someone who you
know you might not have you don't have
to be friends with them you know if you
can get on if you can chat if you can
prove your worth while you know people
will go to you people say I actually
don't mind going to him about a job you
know there are some people that I speak
with on a regular basis where I interact
with them more on Twitter about funny
stuff that they post that I'm like how
that's funny
retweet then I do actually about jobs
yeah and there's times when and like
there's like a weird thing where it's
like oh yeah actually when it goes why
email I'm gonna email you a job but most
but I speak to you like four or five
days a week on Twitter about other stuff
you post they're more like to move for
someone who they can trust because
they're like oh yeah we like the same
stuff because it actually advice for
people in that might that make sense I
like that he genuine being a person and
I really like that so I guess before we
finished me yeah what's going in in Jax
world that you were excited about you
can appraise 200 K mark this year than
the wall yeah yeah hopefully that's my
aim if I don't then you know I'm private
yeah we're gonna find out me there's
nothing to be that excited about okay
yeah as if in a red cap yeah we're
hiring are you yeah we're hiring for
that in your linked
name of you know we are hiring in big
capital letters
yeah maybe an explanation unloads loads
of the stars around it yeah yeah we're
hiring we're hiring across grad level
we're hiring senior crew to we're hiring
every level we're hiring ahead of
contract at the moment to head up a
contract team who've been growing
massively over last year and those are
the things going excited to be about rec
are also building out an office in New
York that my director Jamie is leading
at the moment I think that's prima and
we're real and we're rebranding
oh yeah we're getting a relaunch of the
website which is looking really really
good
hopefully my face passes all over it as
everyone deserves yeah yeah that that
yes there's good stuff going on for me
nothing though it's all right yeah we
commit well let Jax be an absolute
pleasure mate yeah cheers me thank you
yeah you're welcome